des robots déguisée des supporters
enthousiastes du stress bienvenue la
troisième édition du challenge de
robotique sky robe en arrivant les 1000
élèves de 40 établissements n'ont qu'un
objectif en tête prouver qu'ils ont
programmé leur robot parfait
ils ont envie de gagner effectivement il
ya quand même une compétition et c'est
pour ça aussi qui l'on est et ont motivé
toute l'année pour faire des efforts
pour progresser pour résoudre les bugs
c'est bien parce qu'il ya une
compétition donc du coup un vrai projet
derrière
tous ont travaillé sur un cahier des
charges élaboré en lien avec l'éducation
nationale le thème la ryder cup 2018 qui
se tiendra en septembre à saint quentin
en yvelines
un jury spécialisé composé d'une dizaine
de personnes s'est chargé de noter cette
partie de mini golf 2.0 il s'est un
petit peu délicat parce qu'on sent
qu'ils ont travaillé ils peuvent être
parfois déçu parce que ça fonctionne pas
comme il le voudrait parce que les
conditions sont pas les mêmes qu'à
l'école évidemment les robots réagissent
pas toujours pareil il ya des pannes
parfois ils n'arrivent pas à les démarré
voilà des mésaventure qu'ont connus ses
élèves d'écoles primaires de trappes
c'est vraiment décevant parce qu on a
vraiment travaillé et on avait on avait
réussi juste avant de venir on avait
bien réussi mais maintenant
c'est ma il ya des petits soucis ça
permet aux enfants aussi d'avoir le
droit à l'erreur donc on l'a vu
aujourd'hui ils sont préparés à ça ils
savent que le robot il n'avance pas tout
seul et il faut le programmer avant sur
un logiciel
d'autres au contraire ont vu leurs
investissements de l'année récompense et
c'est grâce au travail de l'école afin
de travailler travailler la rive
c'est parce qu'on à russell pour ramener
bien à bien le programme et le challenge
skyrock reviendra l'année prochaine pour
une quatrième édition la thématique
devrait être annoncée en septembre
prochain
[Applaudissements]